and if you've ever taken the tour of  alcatraz  where they brought al capone over  and it was it's quite interesting you  got to take the audio cassette tour yeah  yeah it's uh well maybe they don't do  that anymore oh i don't know  well  [Laughter]  yeah modern times modern i think the  audio cassette alcatrizes up for auction  as well  i'm going to laugh if they still have  the audio consent absolutely  we'll get to the bottom of it you get  halfway through please turn over  uh it's ten minutes to five share yeah  if you're maybe dusting off your walkman  today for your jog yeah it could be  you're a disc player you know your  portable disc this man  that's it  think of it thanks nate  all right oh my goodness nostalgia